[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález hace 4 años el
24 de noviembre del 2016 el gobierno de
colombia firmó con la entonces guerrilla
de las farc un acuerdo de paz definitivo
que llevó a la desmovilización de ese
grupo armado al margen de la ley su
posterior vinculación a la política y
dejó sobre la mesa una serie de
compromisos de ambos lados algunos de
ellos muy ambiciosos al igual que los
objetivos de todo ese acuerdo en total
por ejemplo sólo por mencionar algunos
la transformación del campo fin de la
lucha frontal contra el problema de las
drogas ilícitas la reincorporación a la
vida civil de los ex combatientes
garantías de cambios sociales que
permitieran acabar con décadas de
violencia en colombia y también que
permitieran que el estado colombiano
pudiera hacer presencia en todos los
rincones del territorio cuatro años han
pasado y el acuerdo firmado y los
compromisos entre las partes no han
conseguido desactivar el conflicto
persisten las causas estructurales
persiste la violencia las masacres
el narcotráfico la precaria presencia
del estado y los actores se han
multiplicado y su implementación está
avanzando a paso de tortuga la comunidad
internacional sobre todo la unión
europea ve con mucha suspicacia a
colombia y se pregunta a dónde se está
yendo todo el dinero que han
desembolsado desde bruselas y desde oslo
a esos fondos para la implementación del
acuerdo de paz cuatro años de la firma
del acuerdo de paz en colombia donde
quedó la paz en este país para analizar
este tema saludamos en bogotá a sandra
pérez senadora del partido farc y desde
la ciudad de quibdó en el occidente de
colombia también nos atiende el señor
emilio josé archila consejero
presidencial para la estabilización y la
consolidación le es el recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar sus preguntas
también sus comentarios en las redes
sociales en la recuerdo estamos en
facebook y también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
s arroba sant y luego mi cuenta personal
el numeral o la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 comenzamos y entonces
comienzo por
en la ciudad de bogotá preguntándole
cuál es el balance que usted hace de la
implementación de este acuerdo de paz
cuatro años después
muy buenas noches en santiago y un
saludo cordial a toda la audiencia de
tras 24 horas en balance que hacemos no
es el mejor nuestra mirada de la
solución a esta gravísima problemática y
sobre todas las causas que generaron el
conflicto aún no se han superado en
nuestro país en los territorios en la
colombia profunda persiste el conflicto
se ha recrudecido la violencia tenemos
asesinatos 243 firmantes de la paz
asesinados líderes y lideresas masacres
en nuestro país y este no es un buen
síntoma de avance en la implementación
del acuerdo y dificultades de todo orden
en cuanto a la reforma rural integral no
hemos avanzado aún en la normatividad
porque el acuerdo es vinculante y si no
avanzamos en la normatividad no
avanzamos tampoco en el territorio en
participación política aún hoy después
de cuatro años
no tenemos la participación efectiva de
las de las víctimas en las corporaciones
que publican como por ejemplo en la
cámara de representantes donde se aprobó
se acordó que estarían representadas las
víctimas en sus 16 curules no avanzamos
en la terminación en la paz completa
tenemos que continuar con los diálogos o
el gobierno nacional continuar con los
diálogos con el mn por ejemplo la
erradicación de los grupos violentos que
generan tanto sosobra miedo y terror en
los territorios de nuestro país el
desmantelamiento de los grupos
paramilitares por ejemplo no avanzamos
en el programa de sustitución gradual de
cultivos de uso ilícito no tenemos un
pequeño avance si en el sistema integral
de verdad justicia reparación y no
repetición eso es lo que tenemos hoy
nuestro balance no es el mejor el
balance no es positivo porque son cuatro
años que ya llevamos en la firma del
acuerdo
emilio su opinión para terminar esta
primera ronda para ponernos en
perspectiva sobre la situación cuál es
el balance que usted hace
muchas gracias juan y gracias por la
oportunidad para poder transmitirle a
todos sus oyentes a quienes saludó y
muchísimas gracias por esta invitación
la verdadera opinión de la unión europea
la opinión de la unión europea la
transmitió la embajadora lombard
coincidencialmente hoy mismo y la
embajadora lombard no tiene
preocupaciones de a dónde está
dirigiendo sus recursos está unión
europea confía plenamente en los
lineamientos están el colombiano y
permítame juan señalarles antonio se
materializa eso
santiago
y eso se materializa de la manera más
práctica en la cual una cooperación
internacional puede presentarse y es que
el año entrante
la unión europea va a en lo que tiene
que ver con la reincorporación a darnos
un apoyo presupuestario eso quiere decir
que la unión europea va a exponer los
recursos con los que nos está apoyando
para uno de los excedentes de la
implementación que tiene que ver con la
reincorporación dentro del presupuesto
del gobierno colombiano ese es el máximo
nivel de confianza que puede tener una
cooperación internacional y ese es de
esa manera porque en términos de
reincorporación para darle una idea a
los televidentes nosotros hemos logrado
que 13 mil ex combatientes en sólo dos
años esté en el 98 por ciento de ellos
bancarizados el 85 por ciento de ellos
dentro de el sistema de salud colombiano
el 85 por ciento de ellos con
en el sistema de pensiones extendimos el
apoyo financiero para acompañarlos en su
proceso de reincorporación la mitad de
ellos entre empresas proyectos
productivos y empleos fijos tienen ya un
ingreso y un ingreso fijo que nos
permite a auto sostenerse y el 75% de
ellos contestan que en su futuro con con
optimismo
y luego ojalá ahorita tengamos tiempo de
revisar los demás campos lo que tiene
que ver con víctimas lo que tiene que
ver con sustitución voluntaria de
cultivos lo que tiene que ver con la
implementación de los programas de
desarrollo con enfoque territorial lo
que hace referencia a la reforma rural
integral y si uno se toma el tiempo de
mirar los resultados de no solamente que
tenemos unos resultados muy importantes
sino que estamos dejando las bases para
que se aprovechen los 15 años de
implementación y se logren las
transformaciones del país emilio sandra
yo no yo no voy a entrar en este debate
de buscar quién es el culpable porque
esto avanza o no avanza quiero ir más
allá de eso y puedo hacer esta ronda a
la inversa y emplazó y empiezo con
emilio y aquí usted da unos resultados
hay otra cara de la moneda que ve otro
tipo de resultados pero la percepción
que hay a nivel internacional y que uno
no está en los medios de comunicación de
su país de colombia
es que no se están implementando a la
velocidad que estaban presupuestados
avanzar dentro de los protocolos que
fueron aprobados porque entonces está
esa percepción usted nos da unos
resultados
sandra nos dice de otros y de otros que
están pendientes porque entonces la
percepción por fuera es que no está
marchando
yo soy muy mal comunicador entonces no
sabría por qué como decirle eso pero
permítanme hacer referencia a algunas
declaraciones recientes y nuestras
acciones de particularmente quiénes son
digamos bien dos de los partidos que
éstos apoyan
tuvimos una declaración del presidente
santos con ocasión de los cuatro años de
la firma del acuerdo y contrario a la
manera y lo digo con profundo respeto
para usted contrario en la manera como
usted hacía la presentación el decía
este acuerdo ha salvado decenas de miles
de vidas cuando el presidente santos
dice que se han salvado decenas de vidas
de cientos de vidas miles de vidas
obviamente eso no tiene que ver con la
firma de un acuerdo firmar un acuerdo no
produce no salva vidas lo que salva
vidas es la manera como lo estamos
implementando esta misma semana
el doctor jaramillo que fue negociador
de
de la época del presidente santos y una
persona aquí en el país se respeta mucho
señaló que en lo que tiene que ver con
la reincorporación respeta y admira lo
que está haciendo esta administración
que en lo que tiene que ver con los
planes de desarrollo con enfoque
territorial y encuentra que estamos
avanzando al ritmo que corresponde hace
muy poco rendimos cuenta del proceso de
reincorporación y el editorial del
tiempo que es uno de los diarios más
importantes de el país decía hay que
suspender esta discusión politiquera y
si uno mira los resultados encuentra que
efectivamente se está avanzando en los
ritmos en que debería estar
el ex ministro o campo economista en
jefe del americano de desarrollo durante
mucho tiempo hizo el análisis de lo que
hemos hecho con los planes de desarrollo
con enfoque territorial y decía esto es
precisamente lo que se debería hacer
asunto en el cual hace muy poco el
ministro de hacienda de la
administración santos
el doctor cárdenas coincidía con que si
reactivamos la economía en la manera
como lo estamos haciendo nuestros
territorios va a ser significativo para
el post count luego éste es un tema este
es un tema muy muy complejo es un tema
en donde siempre existen opiniones
depende de la opinión que uno quiera
leer lo que yo pienso finalmente se
centra en cuál es su perspectiva sobre
este tema porque cree usted que no está
avanzando como lo digo que es la
perspectiva que tenemos desde afuera que
vemos que el acuerdo de paz se está
implementando muy despacio cuál es su
perspectiva
mirad sebastián santiago de santiago y
yo por ejemplo reconozco el gran trabajo
el enorme trabajo que hace el doctor
archila por cumplir con el proceso de
reincorporación pero el proceso de la
reincorporación no es la implementación
integral del acuerdo el proceso de
reincorporación cobijará hacia el caso
del 95% de lo que significa ese gran
edificio que es el acuerdo final firmado
en la habana la implementación del
acuerdo es mucho más grande e integral
en su totalidad y por eso nosotros
hacemos por ejemplo mira en materia de
normativa no hay grandes avances desde
mayo desde mayo 31 del 2019 porque la
legislatura que empezó el 20 de julio no
se aprobó ningún proyecto de ley
relacionado con el punto 1 del acuerdo
si de manera que el estado el estado de
la implementación normativa sigue siendo
incompleto nosotros no avanzamos ni
siquiera en la parte normativa
por el congreso de la república no hemos
recibido el primer proyecto de ley que
sea vinculante al acuerdo que lo que nos
vincula la implementación del acuerdo
hasta hoy no entonces tenemos un bloqueo
en cuanto a la normatividad que es
importante para que esta normativa se
sienta en el territorio no es sólo no es
sólo la implementación de los pd porque
los ped incluso tienen una lectura los
pedros a los pedestres and the sun the
sun sustraídos su acción renovadora su
acción transformadora y los
municipalizados ya los micro pérez que
se van a implementar no es lo que se
acordó por ejemplo del acuerdo pero
aparte de esto en el programa de
sustitución de cultivos en extrañamente
extrañamente el gobierno por ejemplo no
permite que se afilien más familias
tenemos el caso de norte de santander
este departamento que tiene límites con
venezuela
en la zona de tibú
a los campesinos no se les está
permitiendo la afiliación al programa de
sustitución gradual pero no solamente es
esto a nivel nacional tenemos una
parálisis de la ejecución de este
programa tan importante que en la de
sustitución de cultivos de uso ilícito y
así sucesivamente nosotros no vemos
avances en en la implementación del
acuerdo en los demás puntos solamente si
hay que resaltar que hay que resaltar
que después de la peregrinación por la
vida y por la paz que se reunió una
delegación con el presidente de la
república se acordaron unos puntos
importantes de eso ya tenemos un decreto
el doctor archila debe reconocerlo un
decreto de la compra por ejemplo de
tierras para los espacios que aún hoy no
las tenemos en seguridad lo más
importante sebastián es que no tenemos
seguridad si no tenemos vida no tenemos
nada no tenemos derechos no tenemos
dignidad y esa es uno de los términos
que
hoy nos tiene bastante preocupados
porque en esos aspectos estamos mal
tenemos asesinatos de de combatientes
el día martes 24 que cumplimos los 4
años de aniversario nos fascina nos
asesinaron otra firma de la paz una
compañera que dejó a su hijita huérfana
por ejemplo y esto es esto es esto es
esto llama la atención
esto no es cualquier cosa nos estamos
contabilizando los mismos muertos que
teníamos en la época de la guerra claro
que no eso pasó mermó pero hoy después
de la firma de este acuerdo cuatro años
después debería de no haber ni un solo
asesinado ni un solo muerto en nuestro
país emilio es claro que éste está firma
de este acuerdo de paz pues obviamente
no iba a convertir a colombia
inmediatamente en un país completamente
pacificado en un país como un país
europeo suiza noruega que eso es lo que
mucha gente pensó que al otro día
inmediatamente la paz quedaba construida
implementada y el país empezaba un nuevo
capítulo es un proceso muy largo y
cerraré una herida de 50 años de
conflicto no se hace de la noche a la
mañana pero lo que se ha notado a nivel
internacional es que si hay un
incremento en el número de masacres y de
violencia a diferentes sectores de la
sociedad los líderes sociales también
defensores de los derechos humanos
algunos ex combatientes como lo
mencionaba sandra a qué se deben estos
ataques y este incremento de las
masacres en diferentes puntos del país
yo ahí se tendría en cuenta varias
varias cosas primero vamos con quien
estoy compartiendo hoy en este escenario
era una ex combatiente es una
combatiente que además de eso por
distintos motivos es un símbolo
y ella ayer y antes de ayer presidió
presidió una sesión del senado de la
república de colombia en el proceso
irlandés que es el ejemplo de europa
antes de que nosotros tuviéramos este
este caso entender que los combatientes
debían llegar al congreso de la
república y poder debatir políticamente
sus casos les tomó 10 años 10 años y
tuvieron que reabrir sus tenemos que
reabrir sus acuerdos y llegar a esa
conclusión en el caso colombiano en tres
años lo logramos en tres años
logramos que participarán en las
elecciones en las elecciones locales el
país colombia
en tres años tenemos una justicia
transicional andando y en el proceso
irlandés que era el ejemplo europeo
antes de que nosotros fuéramos el
ejemplo este tema no sea que no se ha
resuelto ese digamos para que entendamos
un poco al ritmo al cual colombia ha
venido
avanzando ahora en lo que tiene que ver
con las violencias cuando colombia firmó
el acuerdo con una cola farc no un
gobierno del gobierno del estado
colombiano
ln ya existía el clan del golfo ya
existían los pelusos ya existían los
caparrós ya existían los mexicanos ya
estaban llegando a colombia luego la
idea de que la implementación del
acuerdo era en sí misma suficiente para
lograr una paz estable y duradera no era
sino un head line eso no iba a pasar
porque teníamos ese otro problema
de manera y lo digo absolutamente
respetuosa con usted las cifras no no no
coinciden con lo que con su apreciación
inicial por la siguiente razón dado que
había estas otras fuentes de violencia y
lo que uno tiene que analizar si la
implementación ha tenido es un propósito
es ver si la disminución en la violencia
causada por 13.000 ex combatientes que
hoy en día están en proceso de
reincorporación y no están allá afuera
matándonos y tratando de que de que no
nos maten a sus debidos y en todos los
índices índices de homicidios de
secuestros de minas quiebrapatas en
temas de reclutamiento de menores
ataques etcétera todos los todos los
índices son infinitamente menores de los
que ocurrían cuando la franca estaba en
combate luego el gobierno del presidente
iván duque obvio que ha mantenido
el proceso y que hemos logrado como lo
reconocía el presidente santos que lo
que se firmó produzca los efectos en
disminución de muertes de colombianos
bueno lo que sí hay que decir es que lo
que va del año 256 luchadores sociales
han sido ultimados a lo largo del 2020 y
solamente está hablando de líderes
sociales hay otro tipo de personas de
sectores sociales distintos campesinos y
otro tipo de personas han sido
asesinadas eso es una verdad que hay que
decir y eso la cifra lo demuestran
sandra su opinión al respecto
santiago vida en cuanto a la violencia
exactamente nosotros firmamos el acuerdo
de paz por eso para que hay que terminar
la guerra la guerra en ningún país nos
trae ningún tipo de beni a la guerra el
contrario nos trae el dolor sufrimiento
heridas pero pero no es posible que hoy
después de la firma
por eso los reiteró cuatro años tengamos
esta dolorosa cifra de 256 libres si no
eres asignado el 242 243 firmantes de la
paz las masacres las masacres de nuestro
país de reclusión y sobre todo llama la
atención que son las zonas donde están
más militarizadas las zonas donde hay
mucha más presencia de las fuerzas
militares es donde enseguida se
recrudece el conflicto tenemos muchas
amenazas e iu pero aparte de las
amenazas sombras las masacres de los
asesinatos la erradicación violenta de
los cultivos de uso ilícito cuando se
firmó se pactó un acuerdo hacia las que
nosotros encaminamos hoy exactamente
hicimos una estuvimos en una mesa con
las comunidades del oriente del nuestro
país y las versiones son bastante
fuertes en cuanto a las denuncias que
hay por los atropellos y la violencia de
la fuerza pública de los del ejército de
estas regiones y eso es exactamente por
eso es que firmamos el acuerdo para
acabar para acabar todo esto para que
dentro del acuerdo está pactado incluso
el desmantelamiento de los de los
paramilitares de los rezagos de los
paramilitares que son las fuerzas que
señala el doctor archila que son estos
grupos que señala el doctor archila que
son también quienes nos están disparando
sandra que hay de un punto importante de
este acuerdo que la reparación de las
víctimas que ha avanzado las farc en
cuanto a eso mira en cuanto al sistema
integral de verdad justicia y reparación
que hemos avanzado lage después de 11
meses de estar represada de no poder
actuar porque en el congreso nos
tuvieron ahí casi el año en un remo como
corcho en remolino no podíamos avanzar
en la aprobación de la ley estatutaria
por las objeción
que presentaron que presentó el señor
presidente o el gobierno nacional pero
luego de que ha cedido este proceso la
agencia tiene siete macro casos abiertos
en los que nosotros como parte activa
del conflicto armado en que estuvimos
también participando activamente estamos
respondiendo cada vez que la gente cada
vez que la gente nos requiere nosotros
estamos acudiendo a esa solicitud que
hace entonces ahí estamos avanzando en
cuanto a reparación de las víctimas
emilio sus impresiones sobre este
apartado de la reparación de las
víctimas
e
santiago muchas gracias por tocar este
tema
las víctimas son la principal
preocupación de la administración del
presidente de duke nosotros tenemos a
una unidad de reparación de las víctimas
absolutamente fenomenal tenemos una
unidad de restitución de tierras que
está haciendo un trabajo inmenso ambas
de las unidades han reestructurado sus
procedimientos ambas de las unidades
hemos incrementado los los tres
supuestos en ambos casos tanto en lo que
hace a las reparaciones individuales las
reparaciones colectivas la restitución
de tierras en estos 24 meses hemos
logrado lo que no se había logrado en
los primeros seis años de vigencia de la
ley mandamos el mensaje de urgencia al
congreso de la república para que se
extendiera la vigencia de esa ley y
hemos logrado que se extienda durante
diez años más hemos estado trabajando y
en muchos de los países europeos forman
parte del fondo multidonante
y tenemos alrededor de unos 5 millones
de dólares para incentivar las
reparaciones colectivas cuando coinciden
con el pilar de reconciliación en los
170 municipios más afectados por la
violencia y la pobreza ahora estaba
previsto que los bienes malhabidos de
las farc fueran a la reparación de las
víctimas y eso tiene un contenido no
solamente económico sino un contenido
simbólico muy importante porque implica
que con los bienes que no debieron haber
estado en cabeza de las farc se proceda
a reparar a las víctimas exactamente en
aquellos que en aquello que ellos nos
dicen que es el reparador
en colombia los billones son de 12 ceros
y lo que dijo las farc era que iban a
entregar un billón de pesos eso es un
trillón de pesos la mitad de eso nunca
hubiera podido servir para el propósito
reparador porque se trataba de
carreteras y cosas de ese estilo eso nos
deja 500 mil millones de pesos de esos
500 mil millones de pesos hemos podido
monetizar un poco más de 3 mil millones
de pesos eso es un poquito más de un
millón de dólares y tenemos lingotes de
oro por alrededor de 40 mil millones de
pesos pero no hemos llegado ni siquiera
a 100 mil millones de pesos no hemos
llegado ni siquiera el 20 por ciento de
lo que ellos mismos dijeron que nos iban
a entregar para la sede para las
víctimas si a nosotros nos parece muy
importante que eso se haga y por eso
hemos puesto a la sociedad de activos
especiales a completa disposición el
ministerio de defensa completa de
exposición el ejército y la policía para
protegerlos a que nos digan dónde están
esos esos bienes
ahora yo terminaría con esto y es la
verdad yo creo en la onu tanto de los
combatientes y la razón por la que
creadores de voluntarios combatientes
porque tenemos 13 mil de ellos que están
siguiendo su proceso de reincorporación
luego yo esperaría que los los líderes
quienes tienen las capacidades estén a
la altura de sus propias personas que
están comprometidos y que avancemos en
el cumplimiento de esta obligación lo
mismo que estamos pendientes que nos
entreguen la información sobre el
narcotráfico si avancemos en el tema de
a para llevar a mi siguiente punto elías
y sandra y era sobre el narcotráfico que
sigue siendo una gran problemática en
colombia sigue siendo un tema central
transversal en todas las capas sociales
y afecta principalmente las zonas del
pacífico y del golfo de urabá que es la
frontera con panamá en el caribe las
farc
sandra se habían comprometido a entregar
las rutas del narcotráfico y uno de los
cuestionamientos que se le hacen en
estos informes de este balance de cuatro
años
es que precisamente las farc no han dado
a conocer cuáles eran las rutas del
narcotráfico y tampoco han entregado la
totalidad de los bienes este capítulo
entonces que hay que decir al respecto
sebastián y con los bienes al santiago
voy a empezar por los bienes perdóname
que me equivoqué estoy como el doctor no
se ha podido materializar la entrega los
bienes y esto lo sabe muy bien el doctor
archila por razones de orden público ya
que en muchas de las zonas donde están
ubicados algunos inmuebles hay amenazas
de grupos armados que incluso han
asesinado hace poco sino el asesinato de
los compañeros que estaba haciendo el
recorrido por el sur de bolívar y
exactamente estaba recogiendo los
predios que están en el inventario y fue
asesinado
pero mira que aquí también tenemos si
nosotros también
mayo 17 en mayo el 29 de mayo de 2017
nosotros entregamos el listado de todo
lo que teníamos de economía de guerra
que nunca debieron o al otro nos
impusieron una guerra nos influyó una
guerra en 1984 ahí nos inició una guerra
con un fuerte bombardeo que hicieron a
cuatro asentamientos campesinos
en el centro y en la parte sur de
nuestro país y entonces no es que hayan
estado la economía de guerra que tenía
un conflicto que nos que nos tocó
enfrentar a una guerra que nos impidió
ni enfrentar pero aquí ya tengo los
datos mira en bienes inmuebles se han
entregado por valor de 441 mil 503
millones en efectivo 2 mil 500 millones
en semovientes ganados y cabalgar es 4
mil 135 millones en medio de transporte
dijo sandra me queda poco tiempo le pido
por favor que sea puntual con su
respuesta porque debo abortar otro tema
me queda poco tiempo
perfecto pero esto no suma 934 mil 755
mil 718 millones de pesos pero una suma
importante hay que tenerla cuento que en
armamento se entregó sebastián se
entregó 210 mil 172 millones estará
nuestra economía de guerra yo no he
encontrado en el acuerdo porque nosotros
nunca lo obtuvimos una cosa es cobrar un
impuesto y otra cosa es tener las rutas
del narcotráfico las rutas del
narcotráfico aquí están en manos de
otras personas de que le dieron las
licencias para los aviones por dónde
sale y entra en los por dónde salen las
cosas la cop perdón la coca que produce
nuestro país pero por donde entran los
insumos dónde están los puestos de
control esas son las verdaderas rutas
que hay en nuestro país por donde salen
maldades las más de 700 toneladas
métricas que produce colombia sí y quién
controla los puertos los aeropuertos
sean de quién los controla quién
controla las carreteras y las salidas de
los pueblos de los pueblos esas presas
autoridades instituciones
estado que controla son quienes deben de
saber quién tiene la jota del
narcotráfico
me quedan pocos minutos para concluir el
programa elías quiero que haga su
conclusión sobre lo que viene de aquí
emilio perdón a todos nos confundimos
con los nombres hoy todos con todos en
el la conclusión de lo que sigue de aquí
en adelante en esta implementación en lo
que viene para colombia para la
implementación de este acuerdo
según medios estaba muy apenado de
haberme equivocado con el suyo así que
todos estamos en la misma no se preocupe
yo diría lo siguiente y lo que sigue es
que eliminemos en colombia' esta idea de
que hay amigos y enemigos de la paz en
colombia' todos somos amigos de la paz
no que yo piense que le debemos algo a
las farc pero el hecho de que los
acuerdos se hubieran incluido dentro de
nuestra constitución y que la corte
constitucional hubiera señalado que
muchos de los temas que están ahí como
lo ha dicho el presidente iván duque que
se refieren a aspectos de la vida
colombiana que debimos haber abocado
hace décadas con o sin acuerdos es una
oportunidad única porque es eso que
usted al comienzo decía porque existe
esa percepción de que vamos muy lento la
razón por la que existe o una de las
razones por las cuales existe la
percepción de cra va muy lento es porque
son problemas que no se pueden resolver
en el corto plazo son problemas que
requieren de los 15 años para los cuales
está prevista la implementación de los
acuerdos nosotros no vamos a poder
eliminar las diferencias sociales entre
en cualquiera ya que vamos a poder
desarrollar el campo en cuatro años
entonces lo que sigue es
que todos entendamos que esto es un tema
en el cual debemos construir sobre lo
construido y que el siguiente gobierno
tiene una viabilidad histórica lo mismo
que el presidente eduqué de hacerlo en
el largo plazo
sandra su conclusión 30 segundos
rápidamente por favor
y varios retos tenemos el reto no perder
la esperanza tenemos el reto de generar
un movimiento por la verdad y el reto de
la cultura por la paz y de la empatía
que necesitamos urgentemente en nuestro
país y tenemos esos retos pero sobre
todo el reto de la esperanza que si
somos en paz y de construir la paz
sandra emilio muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en
france24 habernos explicado a grandes
rasgos cómo va la implementación de
estos cuatro años del acuerdo de paz en
colombia' ustedes muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros gracias por su
sintonía les recuerdo soy santiago lópez
en france 24 siga con nosotros buenas
noches
[Música]